Republican presidential candidate Tim
Scott going into the liberal Lions Den
and clashing with the ladies of the view
it comes after enduring weeks of
racially charged attacks from some of
the show's co-hosts
he came out and did that dog whistle
victimhood as soon as you say that you
know what he's talking about I didn't
like that he seems to think because I
made it everyone can make it ignoring
again the fact that he is the exception
and not the rule and until he is the
rule then he can stop talking about
systems
he's one of these guys who you know he's
like Clarence Thomas black Republican
who believes in pulling himself by your
bootstraps rather than to me
understanding the systemic racism that
African Americans face in this country
and other minorities he doesn't get it
after smears like that Tim Scott had
enough deciding to challenge the ladies
face to face minus Joy Behar
I'm the exception right you're the
exception maybe even miss Whoopi
Goldberg is the exception I'm on the
show is because of the comments that
were made frankly on this show that the
only way for a young African-American
kid to be successful in this country is
to be the exception and not the role
that is a dangerous offensive disgusting
message to send to our young people
today and 50 Africa 50 of the folks in
our community 13 of the population ask
the question I know I've watched you on
the show that you like people to be
deferential and respectful so I'm going
to do the same thing that was me talking
to you God
come next
only one black senator out of 50. we're
talking about Broadway there's only two
on the other side there's only two on
the other side hi we're back oh we're
arguing over here still I apologize
all right so that happened this morning
Greg one of the things that Tim Scott
said the reason he went is what I recall
you reacting to when the interview or
when The View was first talking about it
about this exception versus the rule and
I remember your reaction at the time I
think he had a similar one and that's
what he really wanted to go on and talk
about there's a there's an interesting
kind of ego play there with sunny
because no one asks her why she is the
exception so how did you do it sunny how
did you how many people to do it and
nobody else could that's a great
question this that that table is the
worst group of progressives ever
assembled because not they claim nothing
has progressed while they're alive that
makes them the worst progress nothing's
changed in 50 years or however long
they've been on the planet I think it's
80 with joy speaking of Joy how
convenient that it was her day off I
think she really hates black dudes you
know remember her uh what did she say
she was lecturing black men on what it's
like to be black systemic racism when
her only black experiences blackface on
Halloween making her the Dylan Mulvaney
of black men so it's a credit to Tim
Scott to go there it was the Lion's Den
the Lion's Den with flatulence here's
what's wrong with the view I did the
view 20 years ago right why has it
changed you know the five is worth with
13 years we cannot turn into that and
I've identified why they turned into
that everybody there is incapable of
observing themselves from the outside
right they can't do the shoe on the
other foot thing which everybody when
you were a kid taught you to do in cases
of bullying or disagreements or
strategic empathy when you're talking
about foreign policy what is it like why
is this person doing this are they
acting irrationally you can they can't
do that they couldn't even do that with
Tim Scott which is why they have this
thing I call it the waiting for you to
finish face have you ever been on a show
where you're I see do that face on this
show yeah when Jessica's talking you
have the waiting for it's basically what
happens is their ears shut down and
you're never going to convince him so
they're just waiting for you to finish
and then they regurgitate their
ideologies be because they can't see
themselves if they could actually see
you strategic empathy maybe if I'd see
Tim Scott's point of view Tim Scott
could see my point of view and then your
mind would change the only people who
can't change their minds are people with
really big Egos and insecurities it's
fun to be wrong I'm wrong at least once
every day I enjoy it they can enjoy it
because their egos are too fragile there
was a column in the New York Times this
weekend called why the view has changed
and it was somebody who had watched The
View for 20 years and her reason she
thinks is because they all just are
desperate to agree with each other and
even with the conservative that's on the
show they don't want to have an argument
which we have no problem with here let
me let's play one other thing for you
Jesse this is about
well about corporate and wokeism watch
here
do you have call for number one
I think Disney and Ronnie have been in a
combat zone for a number of months over
what I thought was the right issue as it
relates to our young kids and what
they're being indoctrinated with I
thought he started off on the right foot
on that issue
I'm sorry sir do not boo this is the
view we accept we don't have to believe
everything people say but you cannot boo
people here please you cannot do it
please continue
so that was a moment where they were
trying to make sure that the audience
was being nice so Whoopi got a chance to
play The High Road Whoopi okay
I have to find out where Joy Behar was
where did she go on vacation because
this would be like me calling Hunter a
crackhead for two years Hunter finally
agrees to do the show and I'm off you
can't do that Joy the only reason he's
on is because of people like you who
called him a race Trader so I didn't
really learn much from this they both
used each other the view uses black
conservatives to scare blacks into
staying voting for Democrats and then
Scott uses the view to go on and raise
money that's fine but Greg hit it he
comes out and he says all this racial
progress that the United States has made
in the last 50 years and they interrupt
him and they say well what is that
supposed to mean we're just supposed to
stop
no we're not just supposed to stop
making racial progress we're supposed to
continue and that's what he said he goes
we're always striving for a more perfect
union but they never have had the
conversation as to how you go about
making a more perfect union we never got
into well should we be teaching white
people to Haiti ourselves well should we
be handing out reparations should we
just be hiring people because of their
skin color even though they're not
qualified we never got into that zone
because all they do is scowl at the guy
interrupt them and go to commercial but
the real question is why won't the left
acknowledge the racial progress why
won't they just say we've made a lot of
progress over the last several years and
let's keep going for more they want
black people to continue to feel
oppressed like they're on the brink of
slavery in order to motivate them during
elections and then they want white
people to continue to feel guilty so
they're shamed into socialism but Tim
Scott was good he just didn't get it
over the end zone like I wanted them to
Judge Jeanine you've been on the
how do you think your experience
compared or I know you don't necessarily
want to talk about yourself but you've
been there when it has been kind of
hostile you know I have I've been on The
View for years when I was a D.A I
actually co-hosted the view several
times and the last time I was on it was
like I didn't have a friend there it was
absolute hatred because of Donald Trump
everything that I had talked about for
years all of the things that I had done
representing you know Crime Victims
women as victims all the good stuff that
they were applauding even the Robert
Durst case applause applause how dare
you be friendly with Donald Trump the
hate on the part of the left is
overwhelming and there wasn't a happy
ending for me on The View I mean it was
like basically get out and you know the
segment's over you know but I'm glad
that that Whoopi's gotten to the point
where she can say you know we tolerate
all views on The View don't boo she
didn't say that a couple years ago right
but what I want to know about Joy Behar
is this if she has of Monday's off I
mean great job right if you could have
the weekends and Mondays up why didn't
they change it so he was on on Tuesday
good point you know I mean why not come
on on a day when she's going to be there
and he can go right to her face look
this is all tribalism we have made uh uh
the racial progress we've made all kinds
of things it's a Democrats who keep
pulling us back think about Joe Biden
right at the beginning of the
administration first thing he does with
Anthony blinken who you know should have
been working on getting an Afghanistan
but instead was too busy talking about
how racist America was they go to the
U.N and they say tell us how racist we
are to get confirmation from the U.N
that we are a racist country uh but if
you had an African-American like Tim
Scott who had the same background you
know uh poor black divorced uh mother
worked 16 hours a day he became a
senator he's now running for president
but he had a D in front of his name
instead of an R are they would have been
applauding him from from the time he
came on the scene but that's not who
they are it's about tribalism it's about
not recognizing hey by the way we've
elected a black man president twice in
the United States we're not going
backwards we're going forward and I
don't want to you know talk about XYZ
and all the things we've done but you
know what it is it is pure base dog
whistle tribalism that they're engaging
in Sunny Hosten she said that Tim Scott
in that first clip there's only one
black Republican senator and he says
there's only two on the other side I
don't know if she even knew that that I
mean if for counting that might not be
the best argument to make but of course
you can comment on that or wrap us up we
did have three Kamala Harris obviously
went to be vice president
um but the numbers are not great on
either side they're even more disastrous
on the Republican side and I do think
that the point that Sunny was trying to
make about exceptions versus rules is an
important one it just had to be couched
in the framework of accepting that there
also has been tremendous progress and
then also owning the fact that majority
of that progress has come on the
Democratic side Barack Obama was the
Democratic president right we have a
woman of color on the Supreme Court she
is a Democrat Clarence Thomas who's been
called out Joy Behar named him obviously
a conservative there but in general the
progress in terms of our institutions
reflecting the people that they govern
is on the left side of the legal
progress happened because of Republicans
the Democrats say filibustered the Civil
Rights Act
that's true okay it's just an absurd
thing to look at the way that the
parties are laid out today you talk
about that we can't talk about progress
I know that Robert Byrd was a dumb was a
Democrat and was a KKK Master before
that or whatever it is if you look at
the parties today you see a much more
diverse set of faces on the Democratic
Republic what is your opinion on that I
think it's because and I to your point
about it's just straight tribalism I
think it's because the policies of the
Democratic Party
take into account the experiences of
traditionally disenfranchised people and
that's what I wish Sunny had talked
about that's the same thing when people
say why wasn't Milani on the cover of
every magazine why is
um Casey DeSantis Walmart Barbie or
whatever they called her which I think
is awful the truth is that
Democrat policies take into account the
experience of women in this country I
mean I was looking at the Fortune 500
CEOs now it's 10 women that's a huge
achievement I was the glowing articles
about that but it's still only ten
percent and I'm not saying it has to be
parity I don't want a job that I don't
deserve but there are definitely more
than 10 percent you notified women to do
that but it's not okay it's not just
that yes it's educational entertainment
which is another way that people are
held back in this country there's a lot
of people that aren't Republicans
because they're told that the
Republicans are against them when
Republicans are giving them a message
like Tim Scott does which is come here
you're gonna have more opportunity in a
place like Florida than you will in DC
or or Chicago but whatever a black man
says something like that the Democrats
call him an Uncle Tom so I think that
there's a message that is that's fairly
effective from the Democrats that keeps
blacks from considering another way I
think that that's actually really
a bit obnoxious frankly to treat
Democratic voters like they don't know
enough to listen to Tom to Tim I'm just
using their words well I'm just using
the view of the view denigrates every
black conservative Clarence Thomas look
at the candidates on the Republican side
running for president we've got two
African-Americans we've got two we have
a sitting president and yet I'm glad we
have a sitting President right so we
don't have other candidates right now
yeah well that's right because they
won't allow them the moment you say this
is no longer a racist country a lot of
people who make money off saying it's a
racist country are out of work that's
right all right Jessica Senate Tim Scott
will be on Hannity later tonight to talk
about his battle with the view and the
2024 race so don't miss that at 9 00 PM
Eastern I winner Brian Kilmeade I want
you to do me a favor I want you to click
to subscribe to the Fox News YouTube
page this is the only way that I know
for sure that you're not going to miss
any great commentary any great news
bites any great interviews coming your
way on Fox you can get it all here on
YouTube so subscribe right now